[Music]
we'll start off with myra in lubbock
texas myra welcome to the show
hello rachel hello dave i love your show
by the way rachel oh thank you
yes
um quick backstory before my question is
i started working part-time
at a
advisor's office and it's been great the
person that was full-time was off for
medical leave
and
she got better and now she's doing
part-time and so we're working together
and things like that but prior to that
it was other people helping the office
that were just interns and so from the
beginning you know i was having to pick
up from where they left off to what they
knew and because she she had to leave
unexpectedly
to do her medical leave
and so point is i just i i just picked
up where everybody left off and i was
doing my best trying my best and things
like that but now that she's come back
it's been very difficult because she
could be
very aggressive with her words and
she
doesn't use that the tone of voices she
uses with me
well she changes her tone of voice when
the financial advisor isn't around and
she said things to me in the past like
i'm the full time don't touch my themes
on my desk um and it's just little petty
things you know like
i don't want my lo your lotion on my
desk um don't move my
okay my paper clips and things like that
my question is how do
how do i go on if i feel that it's just
it takes so much energy because when i'm
in the office i'm always trying to not
do something that's going to take her
off or she's going to be passive
aggressive again or she's going to be
rude to me yeah
whether it's locations when you work
together sure and she's so draining sure
absolutely so myra why did she leave in
the first place what you said medical
leave
yeah so her cancer came back and
thankfully she was
she was able to take care of it
and now her doctor is asking her to not
be full-time so that she can't you know
slowly back into it yeah she is older
and you know she has like no filter and
things like that which
i i'm young and i am not have you ever
wish i was myra have you have you
confronted her at all have you sat down
um and confronts you know it's kind of a
strong word but have you asked questions
to her of hey do you realize kind of how
you're coming off is everything okay how
are you doing because because we find
here you know at ramsay we have you know
almost 1200
team members so working on interpersonal
relationship is something i feel like we
do on a daily basis and usually you find
that people who are hurting can tend to
hurt people right that's saying hurt
people hurt people so as a part of me
thinks that she's there's probably a
level of her that's stressed freaked out
fearful of her own story and kind of
what's going on and it's coming out on
you which is not okay but if you have
you talked to her about it at all
um i have not said it the way you said
it and i think the way you
you're asking me to approach it makes
sense um i have talked to the fa and i
have told him the situation and he's
told me you know she's really hard to
work with and other people have told me
you know just
she's she's a little territorial and
things like that and so it never gave me
the impression that she was
she was acting this way because of the
current situation it just it's giving me
more the impression that that's just the
way she is and this lady
this lady's scared
and she's been scared a long time
and um and all this crap is to cover
over her fear
she's afraid for a job she's afraid for
her health
uh you're
she sees you as a threat
and so the good news is you're just a
sweet lady and i think if you'll just
look at her as someone who's scared
kind of uh put a little different
picture when you see her instead of the
big old mean lady that's rough and tough
and hard to work with instead look at
her as a a little child who's afraid
and how would you treat someone that was
afraid
with pity and with kindness and you
you'd help them and you just how can i
serve you and what can i do for you
and she'll calm down eventually and if
she doesn't
it's just a part-time job go get another
one it's not worth working with jerks
that's the other thing so i mean leave
it ain't that big a deal uh but you
don't don't in other words don't let
yourself be subjected to a toxic
situation because you don't because you
refuse to walk out the door on a
part-time job so just say saytonata out
of here baby done but if you want to try
to work on the personal idea of it which
is why you call
i think you just treat her with
unbelievable levels of kindness and just
because i i'll guarantee you this lady
is really afraid
she's afraid for her job she thinks
you're gonna they're gonna kick her out
because she was hard to work with before
and then she had a cancer problem so
she's unreliable and you know she's
afraid they're gonna put her on the
street and you're gonna take her job if
you look too good so how can i help you
you've been through so much
uh man i just want to support you you're
kind of a legend around here because she
is
legend maybe you're not the way you want
to be a legend but
she's kind of a legend a true statement
nonetheless
but i wondered too even after you know
how work how the workplace has changed
so much since covid
dealing with people now via technology
there's not that that in-person
connection is as much anymore within
companies i mean obviously meyer sounds
like it is for you but you talk about
this a lot in entree leadership though
that
of how to deal with these situations
that it's not going around obviously and
talking
and bashing her to other people so the
fact you went up myra was good to your
leader i think was a smart move but also
to have the ability to sit down with
someone that you work with especially if
it's a for a long period of time you
guys have history and it sounds like you
guys are pretty hand in hand with what
you do
um
getting that it's it is key because it's
exhausting like if you go to work and
you don't like the person you're with
all the time that's the reason that
dread works so it's a reason
i would i would give it a couple weeks
of just killing her with kindness and if
that if you can't get anywhere and if
you continue to have just an abusive
situation i would just go leave
just go get another job
uh it's not worth it yeah and uh i mean
you you talked to leadership and their
answer was a lame-o horrible answer from
leadership well she's always kind of
been that way which means we're scared
of her too
oh my god you know so we don't have
anybody like that that i answer that
about you know
we you get to work somewhere else if
you're going to be a bud around here
we don't do that but um i mean you can
have a bad day you have a bad week but
you don't get to just have the
reputation of being
hard to work with the grouch
that's silly